Mojo Bob saint-cllar ces noms ne vous
disent peut-être rien et pourtant leur
tube cartonne dans le monde entier la
Grande-Bretagne et les États-Unis dont
Dieu que pour les compositeurs
électroniques français une fr Touch qui
séduit même les plus grandes stars de la
musique comme Madonna reportage Yan
fosserier et éc
Janet un tube de Madonna en tête des hit
PARAD rien d'étonnant après 17 ans de
carrière sauf qu'avec la quarantaine la
reine de la pop s'est offert une belle
cure de jouvance auprès d'un Composit VI
chez nous pur produit de la scène
électronique
indépendante quand Mme une victoire de
la
marche musique le H ENF c'est un qui a
été numéro 1 un peu partout dans le
monde c'est la preuve quand même que
justement on n pas obligé de formater
les les chansons avec le succès d'IR W
et autes da punk cette touche musicale
française la French Touch est plus
influente que jamais la nouvelle
génération techno est adulé dans le
monde entier de l'Angleterre au Japon en
passant même par les États-Unis
aujourd'hui un DJ comme Bob vend même
plus de disques à l'étranger qu'en
France on a perdu un peu notre complexe
par rapport aux Anglais par rapport aux
Américains qui eux ont vraiment créé
cette musique donc ce qui a été
intéressant c'est de prendre de voir
comment on a pris toutes les influences
qui venaientent de de de tous les pays
enfin du monde entier pour ensuite créer
notre
musique une piné de disco une dose de
pop le T se poudré de rythmes
électronique la recette a déjà séduit
les plus grandes maisons de disque
Barkley par exemple n'a pas hésité à
signer Mojo un jeune parisien inconnu un
Paris réussi puisque le single Lady S
déjà vendu à près d'un million
d'exemplaires en Europe nous ce qui nous
intéresse c'est signer de la bonne
musique électronique si elle a un
potentiel international tant mieux
maintenant elle peut être instrumentale
elle peut être vocale c'est propre même
des musiques électroniques de pouvoir
dépasser les frontières et qui dit
dépasser les frontières dit chanter en
anglais car visiblement la French Touch
ne fait pas bon ménage avec la langue de
Molière il est très très dur de faire
grouver la langue française la
phonétique s'y prête pas du tout et
l'anglais c'est assez facile c'est joli
et il y a vraiment je te dis des
accentuations qui sont qui sont vraiment
qui se prêtent vraiment à la musique
maintenant si c'est juste quelques mots
en français oui mais dans la tradition
chanson française avec des textes à
rallonge non je
CIS pour ces bidouilleurs de talent
l'important n'est plus de dire des
choses mais de s'éclater en faisant
danser la terre entière une source
d'inspiration pour toutes les stars
établies en quête de
renouveau
[Musique]